[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à travers trois départements les plus
pauvres de france le général de gaulle à
rechercher pour la quatorzième fois
depuis son retour au pouvoir le contact
avec le peuple français certains
parlaient de désaffection populaire
d'éloignement des organisations avaient
lancé des mots d'ordre recommandé
l'absence où l'abstention est cependant
le président de la république a retrouvé
l'accueil chaleureux que lui ont fait
jusqu'ici toutes les provinces et
acclamé aussi bien à villefranche de
rouergue garonnaise à millau qu à
annonay il a pu au cours de vingt
allocution aussi bien sur l'avenir de
l'algérie que sur les problèmes de la
transformation économique du monde
moderne faire appel à la cohésion
nationale
est cependant ces foules dont il serrait
la main ces villes où il parlait ces
pays qu'ils traversaient compte parmi
les plus déshérités
lozère misère dit on ici d'immenses
déserts de pierre des steppes où le vent
courses en obstacles comptait seulement
par des troupeaux de moutons car le
mouton trop sa vie partout voilà la z1
département mais le plus abandonner une
préfecture de 6000 habitants la plus
petite de france si petit si lointaine
que les lignes de chemin de fer levitte
et qu'elle n'est relié au monde
ferroviaire que par une bretelle et l'on
comprend mieux qu'il n'y est ici que
seize habitants au kilomètre carré quand
la moyenne en france est de
78,1 pays qui meurt ou plutôt où l'on ne
peut pas vivre trop pauvres trop perdu
et c'est pourquoi tous les ans 3000
lozériens vont chercher fortune ailleurs
et c'est pourquoi chaque année des
villages disparaissent pierre par pierre
après avoir disparu sommes pas rome et
qui garde encore sur le mont lozère le
village de belles corta des mof
[Musique]
au village de l'hôpital plus de vivants
que les trois personnes qui sont chaque
année bloqué six mois par l'hiver
car l'hiver ici est terrible le vent du
cos est si violent qu'il hérode même les
roches il a rongé le granit ou la
mémoire populaire inscrivit les noms des
deux filles du perron morte perdue dans
la tempête
[Musique]
parfois dans cette solitude désole une
lueur miséricordieuse un village qui se
refuse à mourir et ce spectacle semble
étonnant d'enfants qui dévalent les rues
vers l'école en côtoyant d'autres
bestiaux que des moutons et de
lavandières qui bavardent sans tristesse
mais combien rare car la vie est dure on
vit mal sur cette terre avare derrière
les murs épais construits pour résister
à l'hiver peu de confort et peu de joie
les repas plantureux on les connaît
peut-être aux noces et au fait pour
l'ordinaire c'est plutôt frugal et
comment ne le stresse pas sur ce sol ou
la pomme de terre même grossi mal
sur ses côtes où l'on ne récolte que des
châtaignes cette nourriture de pauvres
dans ces vallées où la seule richesse
possible était autrefois le mûrier et le
ver à soie industrie précaire et qui
n'enrichit plus son homme si jamais elle
pu le faire bien sûr il ya des truites
dans les rivières mais la pêche dans les
ruisseaux commencerait telle une
industrie tout est dur âpre difficile
regardez au marché de florac ces visages
marqués par le vent d'un climat sans
pitié par les travaux et les soucis
d'une terre sans bonté tout ici à son
prix est rien et sans valeur il faut
pour n'importe quoi tant de courage
tant de courage dans ce pays perdu alors
que faire de cette lozère essayez de
l'humaniser de l'améliorer de la
convertir on a commencé en donnant de
l'eau à ce pays c'est cool et ruisseaux
abondent des stations de pompage sont
n'ai pas encore beaucoup mais on en est
qu'au début et autour de prades dub
l'ajout de montbrun la terre commence à
changer d'aspect à ispagnac on irait
peut-être pas cru hier il y a un jour
d'hui 600 hectares de champs de fraises
à côté des prairies où le gros bétail
peut vivre des cultures nouvelles sont
essayés on pourra améliorer ses terres
indigente et hors d'atteinte du vent
terrible qui dessèche tous qui usent les
derniers sol dans les cuvettes et les
dépressions on fait des essais
d'ensemencement que feras ton de la
lozère en tout cas on ne la laissera pas
mourir et l'homme qui n'avait tiers que
du courage au fond des yeux il ya
maintenant de l'espérance
débris calcinés des cadavres une trouée
longue de 100 mètres à travers la forêt
équatoriale c'est la trace du drame qui
a mis fin à la vie de monsieur a marché
on ignore encore tout des circonstances
du drame et jusqu'à présent les
recherches des enquêteurs m'ont apporté
aux mystères aucun éclaircissement
le cadavre a été transporté à l'église
de ndola en rhodésie du nord monsieur
lâche avait pris avec monsieur tshombe
ce rendez vous qui devait lui être funès
les nombres du gouvernement étaient là
pour saluer le corps de l'ex secrétaire
général présent aussi monsieur john b
l'adversaire d'hier
le deuil de l'onu et le problème de la
succession de monsieur h coïncidait avec
l'élection du nouveau président de
l'assemblée générale question certes
plus facile à régler puisque monsieur
mongi slim délégué tunisien rester seul
candidat devant le fauteuil vide de
monsieur air marshal l'assemblée à
l'unanimité des suffrages exprimés a
porté le délégué tunisien à la
présidence de l'assemblée
mais la succession de monsieur amar
celle de comme il était prévu se heurte
à de nombreuses difficultés qui ne
paraissent pas près d'être résolu
la reprise des essais nucléaires jette
sur le monde une nouvelle inquiétude
c'est ainsi qu à trafalgar square la
plus belle place de londres s'est
déroulée une nouvelle manifestation
contre la reprise de ces essais les
manifestants ayant pris leurs positions
de combat ce qui consistait à s'asseoir
par terre la police 4000 agents n'est
plus qu'à les déloger avec un maximum de
douceur et à remplir ses paniers à
salade
cette opération mena les uns et les
autres jusqu'à la fin de la soirée il
n'eut plus la nuit venue que les
résistants de la dernière heure et par
sur les trottoirs mais toujours ainsi
je
au milieu des problèmes internationaux
la vie quotidienne conserve ses
exigences que traduite en france
l'expansion économique
qu'il s'agisse d'améliorer le niveau de
vie ou simplement de satisfaire les
besoins d'une population en
accroissement constant dont le car cette
année a pris le chemin de l'école
l'avenir dépend avant tout des
investissements consentis et
spécialement des investissements de base
qui vise à la production de fonte et
d'acier produit essentiel à tout progrès
matériel
ceci explique qu'en divers points de
france d'immenses chantiers se soit
encore ouvert comme ce magnifique
ensemble sidérurgique qui s'édifie en
lorraine
ceci explique aussi que sur le plan
technique la sidérurgie à pic à
l'échelle industrielle les découvertes
scientifiques les plus récentes comme
l'utilisation de l'oxygène dans
l'affinage de la faune
ceci explique enfin que 12 100 milliards
d'anciens francs seront dépensés d'ici
1965 pour porter la production française
de l'acier à 25 millions de table
[Rires]
le signal de la grande revanche est
donné après 14 ans d'attentes les
français vont enfin battre les athlètes
britanniques avec jocelyn delecour
monsieur sprint ça ne va pas traîner là
pas de pitié pour les anglais y gagnera
également le 200 m et le relais 4 x 100
voilà comment d'un bon on en chie 2 m 3
cela suffit à idriss pour terminer
premier
le 800 et le quinze 100 m c'est bonnet
blanc blanc bonnet dans chacune de ces
deux courses en effet même scénario dans
le dernier virage michel jazy fait la
nique à ses adversaires pour terminer
avec aisance dans la facilité actuelle
de jazy frise l'insolence
dans le coin des hommes forts à l'art
n'a peut-être pas la beauté du discobole
antique il n'empêche que le disque qu'il
a lancée a fait un petit vol plané de 53
mètres 90
où va donc cet athlète si pressé il va
se chercher si je puis dire à 4 mètres
30 du sol
avec michel macquet il faut faire
attention pour ne pas se faire
transpercer le vomi ordinairement se
placer à plus de 80 mètres c'est à peu
près à cette distance qu'il envoie le
javelot 79 m 63 exactement
robert baugé et le britannique ben ali
volt ont couru pendant près de 29
minutes pour en arriver là c'est bien
décourageant pour bâle event bogeys ne
lui laisse aucune chance autrement dit
il a suffi de quelques foulées pas
toujours facile aux français pour
triompher des britanniques par 113 à 99
[Musique]